for
do you want some water before we
start
who are joining us online I am Tracy
Weber and I study meta research or the
science of science at the quest Center
for responsible research at the Brin
Institutes of Health and Char and as you
all know the focus of this evening's
panel is on the impact of diversity on
Research quality exploring the knowledge
Gap this is a very complex and
challenging topic but don't worry
because we have five excellent panelists
who are joining us this evening who have
agreed to help us sort through all of
these very complicated problems and
solve them within the next 75 minutes so
I'd like to thank all of our panelists
for taking on that extremely difficult
task and I'm going to introduce our
panelists to you now seated to my left
we have Lydia Ryman who is a
computational chemist at the University
of maius and a member of the global
young Academy to her left we have Dr
Marietta oer who is a vice president of
the German Research Foundation a
professor of private law and
international and interdisciplinary
foundations of law at the univers gon
Frankfurt and director at the max plank
Institute for legal history and Lego
Theory to her left we have Dr isula
Carla Vice director of diversity
inclusion and talent development and
professor of Prof practical theology at
Roy University boham and to her left our
final panelist in the room tonight is Dr
Gad schadler director of The Institute
of gender in medicine and professor of
gender sensitive research or prevention
research at
CH I'd like to thank all of those
panelists for joining us in addition we
have one panelist who will be joining us
online who will appear behind me shortly
via
magic so I would like to thank very much
Dr GOI gopala kishna for joining us and
she is involved in the Dutch national
survey on Research integrity and is an
epidemiologist at M University and the
Amsterdam University Medical Center so
thank you all for being here our
discussion this evening is going to
focus on the impact of diversity on
Research quality and shortly I'll begin
by asking our speakers to help us each
understand what each of these two very
complex terms mean but before we do that
I'd like you to draw your attention to
the limitations of hosting an in panel
person in-person panel on this topic
this is a global conversation and yet
there are clear systemic biases to who
can be in the room in person in Berlin
to discuss this with us this evening so
to address this barrier we held an
online unconference earlier in the week
where researchers administrators and
funders shared their research
perspectives and lived experience and
this unconference was joined by
researchers in many fields and countries
around the world including Brazil
Macedonia Bangladesh Australia Germany
Scotland and the United States and
Canada Dr Ryman was involved in
organizing this event and she has
accepted graciously the challenge of
sharing both her own perspectives as
well as some of the knowledge that was
brought to our attention during the
event by Scholars around the world and
I'd also like to mention that we are
delighted to be joined by the online
audience around the world and we look
forward to broadening our discussion
with questions from that audience later
as well as questions from those in the
room so I'd like to now begin our panel
discussion since we have many problems
to solve and not much time to do it so
I'd like to VI direct the first question
to Dr Carla and what do we mean when we
talk about diversity in research teams
and what aspects of diversity are
especially important when we're thinking
about research quality big question
thank you so much um first of all what
do we mean by diversity um uh gender
class and race are the main categories
uh but we also talk about age diversity
ethnic diversity uh religious diversity
and um uh in physical ability uh so
diversity is is also in how people think
um diversity recognizes and values the
differences in a group and between the
groups because we are not just only
individuals but um profoundly shaped by
our culture by our family background and
um yeah and what does this have to do
with science um um there are a lot of
groups um with um there are great
talents that cannot develop um um
because Prejudice and bias prevent them
from doing so and the science system
that is concerned with attracting the
best minds and the best people cannot
afford that therefore it is not only an
imperative of equal opportunity but also
in line with the logic of the science
system to promote diversity we need to
Foster these talents whose potential is
undiscovered so far because they have
not been encouraged to pursue a
scientific career um so we think of
women but also now and in these days of
first academic um uh uh students first
generation students uh international
student black students and so forth and
um that's why I think it's really
important um uh to to promote diversity
um in research terms and um yeah that uh
we shows studies show that uh gender
diverse teams for instance produce more
Innovative and higher impact scientific
ideas than homogeneous teams and in
selection uh processes homogeneous um
composed committees come to similar
decisions because they just share the
same value and perspectives and it's
really important to have more different
perspectives and um uh so that risky
projects are uh do not tend to be
evaluated
negatively um yeah re review groups
that's why I'd say need to be more
diverse in peer review and in our
appointment committees because we cannot
see what we cannot see we tend to favor
the people who are similar to us and we
tend to have um more negative um uh um
perspective on people that are un
unfamiliar to us that is this this
Dynamic is described as unconscious bias
and that's why it's really important
what is unconscious we cannot reflect uh
so it's that's why it's important to
reflect about unconscious bias and the
consequences unconscious bias has so
that's my first answer thank you very
much you passed
um okay so I'd like to go to Dr Ryman to
help us expand this conversation we had
some very interesting conversations
during the unconference where we went
around rooms of people from all
different countries and says what does a
diverse research team look like in your
field and Country and we got completely
different answers um so can you tell us
a little bit about how researchers in
different regions and in different
fields might think differently about
what constitutes a diverse research team
indeed we had a really interesting
discussion during the virtual uh un
conference well the divers team it
differs across discipline as most of you
will agree with me whereas when we
consider a stamp fill let us say for
example chemistry which is my area of
expertise a diverse team will mean that
we have different team members uh with
different identities maybe based on the
social social background different
cultural background ethnic group race
and so on whereas if we consider the
field involving human studies such as
Behavioral Sciences uh human psychology
social sciences where data collection is
required diversity in this case means
including participant with different
culture social background cost race
gender ethnic group among others and
also under represented groups uh
minorities and so on but the majority
what we have when based on our
discussion we have found we have
discussed that the majority of stud is
use the weird participant what is weird
participant it is the acronym weird
stand for Western educated
industrialized rich and Democratic it is
an AC acronym which is basically used in
the psychology field and uh this is a
challenge because non weird participant
are excluded for instance if we consider
a particular study where only Weir
participant have uh was were considered
and we try to reproduce the same study
in a non-weird uh count with non-weird
participant in countries such as let us
say India or any Asian country or any
African country we will not obtain the
same res research findings because we
haven't taken into consideration the
cultural difference and all so the to
ensure validity
and uh validity and accuracy and
reliability of research f finding it is
important to include both weird and
non-weird
participants thank you all right so I'd
like to move on now to our second
dimension which is research quality and
I'd like to explore that with Dr oer and
Dr gopala
Krishna when we talk about research
quality what do we mean by that and who
is it that defines research quality and
definitions can differ across Fields so
I would ask our participants to let us
know if they're talking about a field
specific Dimension we will perhaps go to
Dr oer first followed by Dr gopala
Krishna yeah thank you very much so
um of course research qualiity is very
very highly feel specific and
specifically there is a big difference
between the whole field of Natural
Sciences where the last years have shown
an incredible Dimension or incredible
move into the D dimension of metrics
which is always a bit at odds with um
the social sciences and the humanities
however I have a broad overview sort of
being a vice pres one of the vice
presidents of the German research um
foundation so we have to sort of get an
overall map of what can be meant by um
research quality so we try to Define
this maybe a couple of observations um
one observation would be that quality
doesn't necessarily equal or can be um
in some sort of a
yeah um attention with um with with
Excellence because Excellence is a
competitive measure and again this very
much points to metrics so when you look
into metrics this can be potentially
diverse hindering because if you look
what articles are cited most then you
have research which clearly shows that
diverse candidates or diverse um
dimensions are under represented in
metrics so so we look at quality and uh
so the German Research Foundation uh
tries to um make a very big and Broad
picture here something which is
important to note is that we are sort of
not putting this or defining this top
down but this is very much bottom up the
scientists and the fields define what is
quality in their fields and that is of
course Very diverse across Fields it's
very much something which has to do and
then you can sort of diversify again and
you can say well we have um like primary
um quality measures which is um methods
um depth of of inquiry um originality
creativity and then we have um yeah um
adjunct factors which also add to
Quality and that diversity is is
absolutely an issue here um then there
is something like reli or um um yeah
yeah um so it's it's a
[Music]
multifaceted in the future years and
this is something we are always
concerned with okay Dr caval
Krishna thanks Tracy um just inovation
of mine since we are talking about
diversity equity and inclusion the panel
is definitely dominated by women so one
day that was uh just was that intended
or that's a question for you um just my
observation actually looking at the uh
at the panel but I'll jump straight in
and and just give my two sents from
uh research
quality um so speaking from the life and
biomedical Sciences which is uh the
discipline that I am from um then we're
really actually talking
about in internal and of uh a study
that's that's been done so how accurate
how valid is it you know to the study
population uh the study findings uh
speaks to its internal validity and
external validity to the uh so just just
looking at it you know with those lenses
uh that's typically how we would Define
research uh quality and then of course
there's the research Integrity
perspective so really the the
Integrity of the stud which uh according
to um disciplinary Fields um so what is
the best practice in biomedical Sciences
may not necessarily actually be the best
practices uh in a different discipline
so this is this can really actually uh
be discipline uh specific I think that
that is also where we want to talk about
um the fact that research quality in and
of itself in terms of its definition can
uh differ
whereby we talk these epistemic uh
differences as also being part of the
def that included in inclusivity and
diversity uh traditionally uh at this
point in time while that is you know
slowly becoming um more and more a topic
of discussion especially a Integrity uh
circles still it is very much dominated
by the life and biomedical science where
definitions are very much
uh
being D to add epistemic uh uh
discipline discipline differences uh to
uh the uh call for inclusivity and
diversity all right thank you I'd like
to bring Dr Stadler into the discussion
so we've heard about many factors that
influence who becomes a researcher and
what role they might play Within the
research team
so I'm wondering how can the identity of
the researcher and their position within
the research team influence the type of
research that is done and the quality of
that
research well first of all we have
massive data gaps so we don't really
have that many excellent answers to that
one of the very um solid examples that
we have is that for example um if women
H um are senior authors on a paper they
do look at gender differences more so
there's a difference in the questions
that people ask based on their
identities we also have people who um
for example live have lived experience
with certain um U medical conditions ask
very different questions from from those
um that don't have these conditions so
um and so to me kind of I would make a
very strong um case for that um
including um diverse lift experiences
that are relevant the research topic is
really an essential part of of research
Excellence so people who with different
identities ask different questions and
so one thing is just of course we want
to make the best use of all talents that
we have so at the moment by excluding so
many people especially also
internationally whole uh regions um um
due to lack of educational opportunities
in academic access um cannot actually
contribute to our scientific knowledge
and we could just imagine how how
different our science Sciences would
look like if everybody could contribute
but we don't have that at the moment so
this is really an underuse of talent but
the other thing is also um by including
um diversity and gender um questions
systematically in research I would think
that we get much better Diversified
Innovations so we get very much more
Innovative questions and um by that we
really could revolutionalize science so
by really not filling the data gaps um
regarding research teams but also um
regarding including um um heterogeneity
in our research questions um we are
really missing out I think and so to me
it's kind of interesting because um I
would add to so we've done within the
berin University Alliance here and also
with our International collaborators
we've done a little exercise I'm in um
in medicine yeah so um in the Health
Sciences and so which diversity domains
matter there well definitely the patient
experiences yeah so that is kind of a
no-brainer we do always have to include
those and research teams need to kind of
seek that out actively because we cannot
expect our research teams to always
include that yeah so we get patient
advisory boards things like that but
then so we think that so sex gender is
probably also very important to usually
include age and other visible um um
markers like skin color so race um and
region are very important but then also
what we haven't mentioned is care work
so our research teams somehow are
composed a lot of people who do not have
um many care responsibilities or
delegate those or um also um sexual
identity seems to be something that is
missing um in our um way we are
conceptualizing diversity so and also um
what we've discovered when we when we
started talking about diversity so
sometimes it's really a narrow
definition but we would rather like to
broaden it and say like so for example
include also first generation academic
and then we found in our in a student
survey of at the Char here in Berlin
that only 7% of our students do not have
at least one are not affected at all so
in a way I think by more systematically
looking at that we can make the most of
our talents make the most of our lift
experiences and have much better
research I
think yeah and I think one point that is
really important to consider is it's
it's not just about who is doing the
research it's about who benefits and so
when we're saying that there are regions
that aren't represented that aren't
contributing to the research that's
being done those are also resents that
are less likely to benefit from the
research that's being done and the world
has big problems everywhere that we need
to
solve Okay so we've heard examples from
both Dr Stadler and Dr Carla about the
scientific evidence and what it tells us
about the ways in which diversity and
diverse teams can impact on Research
quality I'm wondering if if there are
other examples that our other panelists
might like to share or if any of our
panelists might like to comment on
evidence gaps places where we need
information about this issue and we
haven't done the studies and we don't
have that information
yet all right so we'll go Dr shadler
first and then Dr Oya yeah so so far our
evidence is mostly on um a women versus
men very binary um uh conceptualization
of of uh mostly research teams yeah so
and even there we have massive gaps yeah
so for example in Corona yeah so coid 19
we had um more severe trajectories and
higher mortalities in mortality in men
um still and then women were much um had
a much higher psychosocial burden still
a tiny fraction of studies even reported
um provided gender disaggregated data so
this is kind of like scandalous right we
know this matters and in a way this is
bad research quality but so if we for
gender we are still doing best right um
so what I think what's really missing is
so and then the other diversity domains
usually are studied in a very siloed
manner there are people who look at
Social determinance of Health there are
people who look at race and ethnicity or
regions or age but they are usually not
looking at these factors together and in
an intersectional Manner and I think
this is really kind of something we need
to do better um at and we need to do it
much more systematically
right yeah I agree and I'd like to add
that yeah sort of the classic equal
opportunities Dimension at least in this
country is women men so that's easy yeah
but then there's there are all these
other issues and um lots of the
literature and also the studies we have
are actually from the US context and
there of course the race questions very
big however this cannot be transported
into this country one by one because
here um sort of racial or ethnic
diversity issues are totally different
in a way so this this cannot be like
transplanted and then we already heard a
lot of other issues like uh first
generation academics um sexual
orientation and so so um in in the end
we end up with almost everybody
concerned in some or the other dimension
of diversity which leaves a lot of
intersectionality issues with again
resulting questions which become so
complex that we sometimes we don't even
know what what question to ask now on
the level of um the German research fund
last year we broadened the definition of
equal treatment from women men only to
diversity at large but we didn't offer a
definition because we just don't know
what factors to to put into it so the
question would be to the universities to
the members of the German Research
Foundation to deliver the data and they
also don't have the data sometimes
partially also because of data
protection concerns because
a lots of people don't want to um share
uh issues like yeah disability for
instance um you can't just go and ask
yeah so um it's it's very very complex
and when you start looking at um
intersectionality questions um then also
it becomes very difficult to devise um
yeah testable questions so how should
you measure those complex questions how
do you know that you don't measure just
um the wrong set of of questions or the
wrong set of factors because you just
didn't see them and I might like to add
one more Point um there's a colleague
from mine of the max Blan Society um
Steven vertu he who coined the term
super diversity so he's arguing that
we're actually at least in the west but
maybe globally at a point where sort of
the little boxes of diversity criteria
don't work anymore so we have something
which is cross cutting so we have like
um fluid identities which cannot not be
compartmentalized anymore and also
migration it's also reflecting sort of
the current migration um Dynamics
worldwide and what we heard here about
the weird the classic weird people of
the West which is just not the picture
we have or at least the trajectory to
the future will be that um this is just
not um um yeah the candidates we have
here so again it's very very hard to
frame a research question which is
testable so I I think that's sort of
basically at the at the heart of the
data Gap and that's where research needs
to be
done do any of other panelists have
anything to add on this
point I think it's really important that
we develop a monitoring at the
University so that we know what we are
talking about so we we just made a study
at the r University in bom um and just
to see um how many students are uh for
instance um heterosexual sexual
or whatever how many students um that of
course that um students um they um uh um
didn't have to participate but they they
uh wanted to and and and how many for
for instance first generation students
we have and then we discovered that we
at the University we have uh more than
half um of the students are first
generation students and that's really
something and just to realize that and
to realize uh which um uh what what
challenges are uh given uh with that a
lot of our fifth generation students
they uh have an international um um
Family background um and um and a lot of
um our students are they are
economically really um they they they
count themselves to the poorest or
second poorest group in Germany 40% so
and and and just to see they have spe um
special burdens special challenges they
have to deal with and and uh it's not to
compare with a yeah a middle class uh
student from um yeah and and and and I
think it's really important to to to
gather all these um information so that
we
have a basis a foundation where we we
can uh um develop then a research um and
and to think about diversity Str IES
that could be really helpful so this is
not mainly about research but just by
promoting students who do not feel at
ease at the University because they do
not know the code there how how you
speak there or how you address a
professor or they do not have the right
habitus uh and and just to um and to to
have offers like we have a talent
scouting and um and also groups where
you can share experiences just to to
Empower each other and not to feel lost
at the
University um this is it's not so much
about research but just to to um
um uh to promote the the the environment
for the diverse students that we have
and not just to think very much in
standards and I think that's
neurodiversity is a big challenge too
and um so this is for education and and
the university it's really a big thing
um and and it's of course it's um it's
not easy to handle it in times where you
don't have resources or well the
resources are are not really um big um
but I think that's that's the that
That's the basis to to develop more
diversity than in in science
to yeah and I think as you're talking
about the challenges for students in
Germany who are part of the lower
economic classes it's also important to
remember how much magnified those
challenges can be for students who are
coming from outside of Germany from
completely different cultural contexts
and social contexts and who may also be
visible minorities or have another
identity that's underrepresented in
science okay um so I want to address
next a common objection to diversifying
the research Workforce and sometimes we
will hear that diversity is actually a
threat to Quality and to the
meritocracy and people who argue this
may say that we should select the best
people and it doesn't matter who they
are and yet we've heard many examples in
the virtual unconference about how
things that we associate with Merit are
actually examples of privilege and they
reflect access to resources to networks
and to decision-making power as well as
other things and so I'd like to start
with Dr kopala kishna on what you think
about this
issue thanks Tracy um I think we you
know we we briefly went uh uh a little
bit over this uh this morning uh but
just to reiterate my my point of view I
my my personal position is that I don't
think that Merit meritocrat needs to be
replaced when we talk about EDI issues
and I think that when we talk about um
hiring uh based on Excellence based on
Merit these are usually systems that are
operating in places where there already
is awareness and governance structures
to try to
address um and try to uh and trying to
expand uh the talent pool that is
available uh through sustained uh
structures and standards and I think one
of the most uh uh common examples of
this is trying to reduce uh the gender
gap in various different forms uh from
sority uh to to pay so I think that it
is uh Merit and Merit AC crossy works uh
very well in uh societies where there is
uh this awareness for EDI issues uh
however it needs uh as we already
discussed uh in the panel to be expanded
Beyond J um when it comes to a lot of
the other regions of the world uh I
think that Merit in that case is indeed
uh a privileged
system uh and I think we need to go back
to actually look at you know uh the
basis upon which uh the standards and
structur wa to be hired uh based on
Excellence or Merit these are generally
being created in uh in uh situations
that are already inequitable um and
biased against these marginalized
populations so seing from that
perspective I certainly do agree an
extension of
privilege um and I think that there have
been uh different ways of trying to
address this through quota systems uh
although uh with its own
imperfections uh it is one way of trying
to break the cycle of privilege versus
uh poverty or lack of resources uh
giving uh dedicated scholarships uh to
certain groups I think that these are
ways uh which have been uh imple put in
place to try to expand uh the diversity
of the pool upon which uh we need to uh
ensure is representative of our
society so I I don't think it's an
either or uh argument I think that it
really it depends on uh the kind of uh
context in which we're talking about
Merit yeah and I think that's a bit of a
challenging issue because on the one
hand we can say within this context it
may work but on the other hand the
research Workforce is highly mobile um
and researchers for example from the
global South are often applying to
positions to funding agencies that are
located within the global North and so
when the playing field isn't level
across the board that's a huge issue for
the mobility of those researchers for
the ability of those researchers to be
recognized and seen so I'd like to go to
Dr Carla now what are you thinking about
this issue of is the meritocracy a myth
is it working does it not work what are
your
thoughts um I I just uh already
mentioned that for me A diversity
strategy uh is an a very um good
instrument to promote highly talented
people who um uh H haven't been
encouraged to promote a scientific
career so far um by
um so uh in in in this direction I would
say diversity is uh fostering quality
research quality but of course there are
some in the reality there are some
dangers or risks and uh when um uh
diversity strategies are um used just
for identity politics for instance and
you uh and and so the politics is in the
forehand and not research work then that
that's a problem or that could be a
problem and so and and furthermore I
mean in order to make a diversity
politic you have to to make um you have
to um to to make differences and and and
differences I mean on the one hand we we
stabilize uh differences when we just
name them but um in the end we would
like to destabilize these differences
because we say it's about talent and not
about male female black white and so
forth so this is a sort of a paradox we
have to live with and there is no in the
best of all worlds maybe there's a
solution but I cannot see that right
now Dr Ryman what do you think yeah so
uh I tend to think about equity in
research so what is equity in research
it means to normalize resources that is
in terms of funding infrastructure
equipment uh instrument and so on but
from a global South perspective this is
a real challenge because let us remember
that from a global South perspective we
have limited funding we have limited
resources along with that there are
other issues for example we have load
shedding issues in many countries in the
uh Global South we don't have access to
uh all the journals because universities
can't afford to subscribe to all the
different Publishers as well and we
cannot publish as Open Access because we
don't have the funding for that so these
are the issue that usually countries
from the global South phase uh Global
South phase now if I have to consider a
lead researcher from a global no who has
a better quality better access to uh
resources to instrument maybe they have
the latest instrument or equipment as
well even access to Mobility so this is
considered as meritocratic so as you can
see if you compare a researcher from a
global s and a researcher from a global
no it is an inequitable system so does
that mean in terms of research quality
if we have to talk about it uh obviously
the one from the global North will have
a better research quality compared to
the one from a research South but does
does that means that research from the
global South is of poor quality just
because of limited resources and funding
I think this is a very interesting point
that we need to ponder
over and so that raises an interesting
question um one of the things that we
talked about in the unconference is in
cases where quality requires resources
how do
we Implement quality and advocate for
quality in a way that it does not become
a barrier to diversity where those who
have more resources are being recog Iz
for doing higher quality work and those
who have fewer resources are therefore
evaluated as having lower quality I'm
wondering if any of our panelists would
like to address that complicated
issue well so I absolutely in fields
where um resources are needed to do simp
to Simply do research yeah so so in a
way that this this applies always yeah
we need um to have educational resources
resources and some free time and space
so it's always like a little bit of a
privileged situation is necessary to um
conduct any research at all kind of
Virginia wolfes Room of One's Own so so
why uh we do need some space and and
head space as well to do research but in
a way um I've also um seen in
collaborations that that cut across
resource richer and research poorer
areas that Innovation flew um flows both
ways so that from the um research poor
areas a lot of local um very good
Solutions that do not require such um in
medicine especially so so you can use
them also um for resource richer
environments um and so it is not so I
completely agree where where um I think
in the Natural Sciences um where we need
a lot of um it's really resource
intensive that will always be a disad is
disadvantage but on the other on the
other hand we have a lot of areas where
where we could make much more together
and so kind of to Foster these
collaborations would be possible then
the question is like so how do we do
this like so what I've seen what works
is kind of like collaborations that are
very um focused yeah so that that you
for example say I'm I'm collaborating
with a certain country and with and I
because in research we also need to take
the the local context into account and a
lot of our research Solutions are not
especially transferable yeah so for
example um what does ethnicity mean and
what what kinds of ethnicity matter
really varies dramatic Ally from region
to region and um how that matters for
health as well so we um I think we do we
can learn from each other through
collaboration and but at the same time
we do have to have deep roots in our
regions to for example fully understand
the healthcare system and what so we
cannot just transplant um Solutions and
resources from one area to the other um
we have to adapt those and so so to
forge and a lot of this really relies on
personal connection yeah so so to to me
it's kind of interesting like so how do
we do how do we do that and um yeah so I
think I don't have good Solutions um but
but I think we could do much better if
everybody kind of like um would would
also pick an additional region like like
what we have with with with um um City
Partnerships for example and so have
those um between resource richer and
resource poorer um uh areas I think that
would be very
advantageous so I'd like to get uh Dr
ryman's perspective on this what is
collaboration that is responsible that
is respectful that is advancing science
and advancing skills for both Partners
look like when we're thinking about
countries with limited research funding
versus countries with a lot of research
funding yeah this one I can share my own
personal uh experience so usually
collaboration this is what we do in the
group that I am where we do collaborate
with many different uh uh teams across
the world and it is really fruitful and
this is how we have become very
productive as well so this is one way
but at times uh most of the times we do
try to collaborate informally because it
is through personal contact like like
you have just mentioned and so on but if
we try to formalize the collaboration
you know you have so many administrative
work you have the agreement and so on by
the time that you are agreeable on a
common agreement and so on this take
quite a while to be able to do so and
also you have to be very specific about
the number of authors and so on so this
is quite an issue but at times even if
you have an informalized collaboration
you have some ups and downs at time it
doesn't work for example uh quite
recently we have been collaborating with
someone but unfortunately it didn't work
although that we were already working on
that for example they submitted their
work without even us knowing about it so
you see this is because of an formal
collaboration so it really it really
depend we have to have a responsible
collaboration and
[Music]
also well uh you can have many different
uh research teams that can be considered
as diverse where we are including almost
everyone but are we really uh inclusive
so that is the next uh question that we
need to ask our because everyone voice
needs to be heard at the table we need
to listen to everyone so as to to be
feel uh
included okay I'm going to stick with Dr
Ryman now um before we move on to others
so can you offer your perspective on why
it's so important to have research
that's driven by researchers from the
global South yes first of all is to be
inclusive within the scientific
community so this is the first point the
second point is that researchers from
the global stff have made significant
contrib contribution despite all the
challenges that they face thirdly
research from the global s offer
different diverse perspective that might
be overlooked by the global nor for
example conducting research on malaria
tuberculosis Aids HIV for example This
research need to be conducted in region
where these diseases are prevalent in a
more effective approach and fourthly
there are lots of unexplored potential
in the global South for example Africa
has a huge biodiversity resources that
has the potential to provide Noble and
potent drug candidates but remain
largely unexposed due to limitation of
uh research funding and resources so
this is something which is important to
improve the health system for example
lastly but not last but not the least
there is no lack of talent but I think
there is only lack of opportunity in
that case thank
you okay um so we've we' been talking a
lot about researchers and researchers
themselves but we all know that
decisions about who does research what
research is conducted the quality of
that research and whether or how that
research is shared isn't simply made by
researchers so we have funders we have
um leaders at research institutions and
we have Publishers and editors as
examples of other stakeholders that are
influencing these
decisions and so I'd like to hear from
our panelists how how a lack of
diversity amongst these other
stakeholder groups shapes the research
literature and influences who benefits
from research and I'd like to start with
Dr gopala karishna and then hear from Dr
oer thanks Tracy um if I can actually
just go back and maybe just um add a
point on responsible collaboration I was
really uh literally on the tip of my
thong uh was uh to mention these other
stakeholders olders uh primarily funders
I think can have uh a big role
influential role in being able to uh
ensure that research that is being done
in the global South uh that the roles uh
of these different um uh collaborators
are indeed uh responsible um uh uh
Partnerships that are formed uh and I
think that as king at the last uh World
conferences on Research Integrity the
cape toown statement uh really made a
strong push uh to speak on the issue of
responsible collaboration particularly
in the global South um that helicopter
research and ethics dumping still
prevalent issues uh that go on where
Global South Partners quote unquote are
often data collectors um and not fully
on board uh as uh collaborators who are
uh included uh in terms of Partnerships
uh authorships um as one form of
illegitimate partnership but also terms
of building and transferring expertise
um so I I do uh strongly believe that
funders have a strong uh role uh to play
in this uh given that that is an
quintessential carrot and that they hold
for many research uh
communities uh and with respect to
Publishers uh I think that there is lot
of movement and discussion uh about
ensuring that peer review um is
Equitable uh that that there is a
diverse pool of reviewers similar very
similar arguments to why we need a
diverse pool of researchers uh to
improve research quality I think that
it's a mirror effect uh uh the argument
goes both ways uh in other words that we
also need a diverse pool of uh reviewers
um and finally I think that we also need
to ensure that we are able to assess uh
the different policies and governance
structures that are put in place so
while they may be value based we talked
about evidence gaps I think it's
important to not only um uh instit these
policies while uh trying to address
these evidence gaps but also to have the
flexibility to change these policies as
new evidence
emerges thank you very much Dr oer would
you like to expand yeah I'd like to add
um of course funders are supremely
important for fostering or hindering
diversity because if we say that the
whole um system of science is basically
a weird practice that is a western
Enterprise it's all about Merit then
putting funds into where the Merit
already is of course heightens those
differences so there is and that is
actually being done by the big found big
funer funders here in Germany at at
least um well I can speak for for the
German research fund that's why there is
supreme um um yeah awareness that this
is an issue and that diversity has to be
an important part of every single um
funding um issue and decision and that
funding decisions when they are sort of
looked at at a as a as a at a grand
scale this issue really has to be part
of the picture so that um the lens of
the focus is narrowed
um that having said however one thing is
and maybe this is something actually it
came up here a couple of times even
though quality needs resources so
funding is extremely important for
quality and thus also for yeah bringing
diversity into
quality it's totally not the case that
you just put money on researchers and
you get quality or you get Excellence
that's just not what follows CL so um
actually in a big funding structure um
there should should be awareness there
has to be awareness and that's something
which is very necessary that sort of um
research fields are aware of that that
quality can always grow Grassroots like
from bottom to top and then you have to
look where it is and that's actually
something where the global South can
totally contribute to science here and
actually does so so in my Institute we
have lot of researchers from the global
South we do research in archives in the
global South which is something which is
um totally enriching what we've done
here in um the humanities work up up to
now and that can be done under totally
different conditions it opens up other
questions which weren't on the landscape
before and there you don't sometimes you
don't need all this um or yeah you can
do with a little funding but you get a
lot of results so it's it's not s such a
such a simple picture but of course just
to highlight this again of course
funding is supremely important and um
yes um diversity is a big issue and
we're actively um into fostering it
definitely so I'd like to expand on one
of the points you raised um you talked
about funders and supporting quality and
one of the challenge with funders is in
a lot of fields and those fields can be
at very different places in regard to
their discussions about the criteria of
quality so often when you're talking to
funders about encouraging them to make
changes in your field they'll say well
that's your field but we fund all this
other stuff and we can't move in just
one field without having something that
applies to everyone and so how do we get
around this challenge of being able to
move forward in the fields that are
ready and that we know absolutely need
to make changes in where there are clear
standards while still allowing other
fields to evolve at their own pace and
have their own conversations well you
have a you have to have a very
professional funding organization with
top researchers doing their research in
their as sort of meta research on how
how science is moving along and where
it's moving and there has to be openness
and sort of not sitting there and just
doing what's been done all along but
just sort of moving into new Fields
because seeing that fields are moving
there then there is also something um
like in big funding decisions when you
have all Fields competing with one
another of course you have to have a um
you have to have yeah um decision boards
which are um diversely um yeah sort of
have a diverse occupation where all
fields are represented and then you you
have those debates you totally have
those debates well this is Excellence
for you but that's not Excellence here
so how we do do we talk about this and
that's something which um which is also
very productive and which is um which
brings up new issues basically every
year something new comes up and then
actually this is also very teaching you
learn something
so yes there are the fields there are
sort of compartments and everybody has
their research culture but there is also
something which which unites all science
in a way all scientists can talk to one
another because everybody's basically
interested in the same in finding out
something new wherever this is whoever
does it it's wherever it on the world
and that is something very yeah this is
driving science and this that's the
spirit you have to get at when you try
to do good
funding all right um so I have a few
more questions for our panelists but we
are also approaching the time where
we'll be taking questions from the
audience so for those online I would
encourage you to submit your questions
via the SLO they are being monitored um
and we'll have a chance to share some of
those questions with our panelists soon
soon so I want to move towards exploring
Solutions and actions that we can take
to increase the diversity of the
research Workforce we've heard about
some examples of solutions already but
are there evidence-based interventions
that we know are effective or are there
things that we have tried that we know
don't work and so we should stop doing
them well so from organizational
development we very clearly know that um
basically delegate these um issues to
diversify um organizations do do not
work if they are really on a on a low um
uh um organizational hierarchy level so
it really needs to be a strategic and a
and a kind of like a task for everyone
but including the top yeah so and really
to set um clear goals and really monitor
those Quant quantitatively and
systematically um we cannot do without
um often we we find really so the
problem is these problems in um defining
diversity re and also data protection
here in Germany hamper our ability to
describe the diversity that we have in
the population um in our students and
then do our hierarchy levels mirror the
talent that we have going into our
academic institutions but we need to do
much better really understanding that
and then come up with evidence-based in
um interventions so for example what we
found just like you described that at
the Char we have about a quarter of our
students are first generation academics
it was totally surprising to us and we
have currently no services to them we Al
um for them we also found that they um
that we have a lot of people living with
invisible um diversity domains including
chronic disease that we had no clue
about and so um it so so we need to do
much better in terms of really
systematically um monitoring diversity
gender and diversity and then
together with as in a part participatory
way really develop interventions that
that um that work what we have done so
far works I would say extremely
suboptimally yeah to delegate this to um
to uh some uh uh parts of the
organization that have very little say
over strategic decisions does not work
we know
that all right so there are other
panelists that would like to comment on
this okay we'll start with Dr Carla um I
think it's uh really helpful to
establish unconscious spice trainings
for management people for uh appointment
committees and uh professors um um
because uh a lot of people they just um
they don't know that they are biased or
that they have prejudices and it's just
helpful to think about it and to reflect
it it uh this won't solve every problem
but it will help and uh so we started
with that and uh we can see that yeah
that people are really surprised and I
thought I wouldn't be biased at all and
now I see that this is not true so this
this helps especially in selection
commes and um the second thing is that
um I I very much agree with you that you
you I mean I'm I'm at the top as a
proctor for diversity or vice president
and and it's very important to to have
um um decentralized activities um I also
always say that to to the students and
and to the staff I I cannot do it for
you you must do it and that that's why
we have um we have a central an
anti-discrimination officer but we also
have diversity officers in all the
faculties uh student officers and and
it's much easier especially for the
students just to talk with them because
they are not afraid of going to the
recette or something like that uh so I
think it's really important to combine
both um so governance plus these
decentralized activities and and um
officers and um and then third I think
it's just a matter of empowerment um uh
just that for instance uh I I always
encourage the new professors that that
with with uh that come to to buom uh to
to um talk with talented students that
they apply for a scholarship for
instance just to talk with them they
need to be addressed directly addressed
because first generation students don't
think that they could apply for a
scholarship at the student Fus they they
never would do that and so you have to
encourage them to say now go for it you
can do that so it's
it's just a a matter of everybody in in
the staff in the um of of professors and
teachers lecturers and um and and for
for myself I mean I I was the first
academic uh um student and woman I I
grew up at the farm with three brothers
so feminism was sort of a strategy to
survive and um and and and but I never
would have had the courage to pursue an
academic career if I wouldn't have spent
a year in the US only in the US I was
encouraged to to to do that because
first I experienced female professors to
my time there was no female professor in
tubing I I could listen to or talk to
and the second was that this female
Professor they talked to me and said
yeah just go for it you can do that and
that was just for me so surprising and
without this experience I never would
have chosen to to just um make um
doctoral research work and then
the whole path you know and my last
point my last Point um I think that we
need reliable and transparent career
paths uh we have a big discussion uh
around regarding this issue in Germany
because it's really a
mess we have these uh temporary
contracts and we have this um I mean
temporary contracts may be okay but it's
just so confusing in Germany because you
don't have really career stages like in
it's common
internationally and and that's why we
develop now um a career Concept in bhom
with that you are a doctor and then
postd doctoral and then assistant
professor and pro associate professor so
that you really know what can be a
career an academic career and and I
think this is really important
too all right you have 30 seconds
because the bearer of audience questions
is
[Laughter]
here okay let me just totally con yeah
sort of uh concur with that um career is
or career possibilities is actually the
most Supreme issue we
have I'd say yeah diversity is super but
it needs to be managed and monitored so
if it's if we don't know what we are
doing things might go wrong and let me
just use the last few seconds to mention
one thing rigid quotas especially since
we're all women this can have a really
real backfire because once you're there
you're always on the panel you're always
in the hiring committee you're always in
that committee you're always in that
committee and you're the only woman on
the faculty so it means you have to do
them all and that's kind of you know
that's actually a downside so this needs
to be worked on so how is diversity
working for those people who are in the
system and who do get the
opportunities but again it has a
downside well thank
you all right so I'd like to thank all
our panelists for that discussion so
joining the panel we have ulie deagle
who is here to represent the questions
from the online audience and then we
also have a microphone in the room for
questions for people in the room so I'll
maybe go to ulie for the first question
while audience members are deciding what
they might like to ask and we're getting
a microphone to them in fact we don't
have a question from the audience we
have we have an online audience but they
are very they're probably also still
thinking about those questions so okay
uh the floor is open and I already see
several hands uh up and so the first
question goes to you in the back there
will be a microphone in a
second thank you so much for the
wonderful um discussion on this topic
but I would like to
ask if a professor or a senior uh
academic person is trying to establish a
research team at what
point when you weigh um you want to have
a diverse research team and are also
interested in Merit how do you balance
it knowing fully well that if you want a
diverse research team you might want to
probably recruit PE researchers from the
global South and if you compare their
maybe the publication qualities and
things like that it might not you know
if you place it on the same pedestal it
might not be the same with a candidate
from the global North so how do you
balance diversity and Merit
now okay would one of our panelists like
to
shall I answer just from my own
experience with having with having
assembled such a team I just know it
when I see it I know when I see research
quality and that's that's totally um an
open question whether it comes from the
global North or or from the global South
and how they interact so there are
questions which are interesting both to
the global North and to the basically to
the whole world like the foundations of
property yeah so what are property
rights for instance in water or in air
or um climate etc etc so I'm a lawyer so
I take this from the legal side but
nonetheless so natural scientists is is
even easier it's even more obvious that
there are combining questions so if you
say you have a global issue or you have
an issue which is really interesting to
the world then there is of course a
person on the global South who has
something to say about it and that's how
I picked a person and I don't care
whether like the Publications are in the
reviews I know no I take I'm interested
in whether the research is interesting
and then we can grow together and the
team forms and that's how this is
done thank you unfortunately we have uh
probably many more now that the the
online community active U so we have to
uh be brief with questions and brief
with answers that was very good so thank
you I'll just before before I'll move to
you I have one question coming in from
Marina and her question is what do you
think about about establishing gender
quotas in high hierarchy research
positions what can we do about the glass
ceiling in science and academics anyone
to so well there's always this
discussion so quots work and incentives
work both of them work um the thing is
like so if we want to do it Merit based
then we need to start at the base yeah
so if we start with students and give
them incentives or or quoters um so um
then we then we um develop all um all
talents that we have yeah so so um but
if you starts um to apply the quotas
only at the top there can be a little
bit of a problem yeah so so we needs to
um quotas need to apply to the whole
Pipeline and really so that we reflect
um in higher levels really what we have
coming in in terms of of talents yeah
and so and that's why I'm both work both
incentives work and and quotas work um
so we can use both thank you now we have
a question from the floor yeah um first
of all thank you for this um um
interesting panel which I think we all
violently agree with you but um coming
back to maybe a barrier to M you know
forming diverse teams having diverse
study subjects and this is a question I
guess for Professor Stadler but also for
Professor a with her kind of legal head
on um how do you especially in the kind
of German context get about and you
touched on this professor Stadler before
uh the data protection um aspect that we
have obviously for very obvious histor
historic reasons in this country about
people um uh being open about um more
protected diversity Dimensions possibly
yeah um so we've just run a number of
studies using a diversity minimal item
set where we um where we voluntarily ask
people to self-identify so there are few
principles for that which is that
there's always the for each diverse
domain the option to say um um I choose
not to answer so and I think that's very
important to include that um so because
people are very willing to um to answer
one diverse domain but maybe not the
other they find that too personal the
other thing is that we did need to then
really think about our research
practices so for example we've just
studied the charite as a whole
organization with its 20 uh, plus people
so that requires a lot of trust we um we
are not analyzing the individual data
ourselves we um we have that um do by a
um external collaborator who doesn't
know the people because if I'm um like
uh basically combined
um let's say 10 diversity domains I I at
individual persons so we cannot do that
yeah so so we um we I would recognize
probably colleagues and and that's why
we um we Outsource that um so there's
definitely um a very uh strong level of
data protection necessary and if I could
have a wish then I what I would really
want a wish for is a diversity data Safe
Haven where we have kind of like an an
identifier um for for certain people and
then so we could use um um all all kinds
of multi-domain diversity assessment um
but the data would never leave that
diversity data Safe Haven so I could um
link that personal identifier with for
example mortality data or disease data
and then these are sent to the diversity
data Safe Haven are analyzed there are
never are never shared with anybody I
just I get a synthesized a synthetical
data data slice as a researcher to
develop the code I sent that to the data
um diversity data Safe Haven and out
comes some results and I think so this
if I could wish for something that would
be kind of like amazing because then we
would kind of have the highest privacy
protection and at the same time like we
we could um really be much more um for
example for um do much better with small
Min um minoritized groups Dr you address
directly just a very brief followup yes
totally that's the way to go is you do
Anonymous research and statistical
research so that's to totally okay I'm a
bit skeptical about safe havens for data
where the data never leave I don't know
so I don't know but
anyway we do the same and as long as you
can't identify the people you get the
data however you have to ask the right
questions and that's the hard part
because um what to ask and what to get
back if you don't really know what's
there in the first place so it's a it's
an ongoing
project are there a further question
from the floor
yep yeah
okay uh thank you for the nice introdu
uh like discussion I have a question
about like the equality based on my like
observation so I work in the Institute
of Pharmacy uh in F berin and I observe
that there are more female um students
let say males and then I I don't know
what's the reason okay let's just assume
that female students are like like they
study harder or somehow or like maybe
smarter than the males and then does
this mean that when you recruit someone
and then you only recruit like the high
quality student let's say the female
students and then maybe it can cause
further in equality let's say how do you
balance between the marage and the let's
say uh the the diversity who wants to
take this one
on well the German Research Foundation
says um you try to um Implement
diversity by hiring the Lesser
represented gender so it's not always
women so that means when you have a
which exists there are Fields where
there are like 80% women students or so
then you have the reverse problem and
the reverse issue and of course then the
men have a have have a have a claim to
diversity
sure there is a I'll we'll get to you in
a second there's a a question coming in
which I think touches upon an issue
which has not been uh discussed so far
comes from Katarina and she asked how
can we recognize and acknowledge the
efforts and expertise of researchers who
invest their time knowledge and activism
into diversity at
universities shall I try to answer this
so well this is a labor of love right so
we are here the enthusiastic view but I
really believe that we need to do much
better so this is a task for everyone
for everyone who does research to
integrate um diversity and gender
analysis into their research content and
diversify their research teams if we
remain with the enthusiastic view we are
not doing enough um and really we owe it
to research quality to all do better and
to rope in all the ones who are maybe
less enthusiastic and I do think there
are a few incentives um that that we can
use of course um it is much more fun to
have be more Innovative as that is that
in itself can be quite rewarding but we
can't just rely on that so um definitely
using incentives in additional to um
monitoring and quota and and Leadership
really I think is very important and of
course like we can use Awards we can use
other we can use dedicated funding so to
really incentivize the people who help
us spearhead this thanks there was
another question
yeah
okay hi uh we talk about that different
people from different backgrounds make
different questions and also we include
these uh who benefits from and who gets
impact by research so I was uh wondering
in your experience or as a future
potential how much do you see or or did
you work with including groups of people
with that don't come from Academia
uh backgrounds but they are in touch and
related to the subjects that you are
researching maybe because of a personal
background experience interest and what
difficulties you see in engaging this
group of people in your
researches so we routinely use um
patient advisory boards um to advise us
on the lift experience um living with
certain chronic conditions or
disabilities um as a person who is not
having that lift experience so for
example I've done HIV research um with
black men who have sex with men I would
never dare to do that without the
community members so um and of course
there are lots of barriers then we
researchers are real nerds right we we
have our special words we have our uh we
are often not very acceptable uh um
accessible in our our wording in our
language so it really um um
it it requires of us to to um do a lot
more than just science communication but
rather really try to to become um
use essential language more more um
everyday language um trans and translate
and take this seriously um so by
including people with with lesser
education to also use um simplified
language um and and maybe also more
visualizations more um videos and like
really to to Really collaborate with
with this um with with these Community
groups I think we've had the experience
it works very well may I just add that
you're you're sort of a poster child of
all this um and at the sh I can tell you
that we are not all true to what you're
preaching here so we should do more
about that so the impression that the sh
is just us heaven for all those things
is unfortunately not true um
okay I we'll do one more question and
then we have to close because we're very
close on time okay so you get the the
last question thank you I just want to
ask about this H language diversity you
know we have different people with
different language and we still want to
get the best which we are talking of the
Merit in research now we are also
talking of the global the global you
want to take from Africa and you want to
also take from maybe Germany here and
the language are not the same how do you
balance
that yeah so coming from an Institute
where English is the working language um
globally the German language is a total
um minority project yeah so um there
isn't any hemony of the German so when
you're in the global world it's English
basically or if you're in the
frankophone or um like Hispanic areas
it's French or Spanish so these are the
world language but actually it's English
so that's basically the answer and
that's where like there should be a
statistics on how much worldwide science
is published in English probably it's
like 90% or so and I think this this is
also a task for the for all countries as
so to kind of really take so what I we
are completely bilingual lab as well but
I encounter a lot of fear often
especially in people for for example for
Eastern Germans they they have learned
Russian and they have not um they're not
so fluent or um in in English um
especially the younger ones are are
usually um quite bilingual but they also
need takes practice Yeah and Goodwill so
for example we have policies that every
person can speak in their own language
and then either we translate or um so or
it's simply acceptable to not fully
understand so before I hand back to
Tracy I have to apologize to those that
have not been able to ask their
questions and so for not got an answer
we have several questions in the chat
still and I'm sure you have questions
here but you will announce that there
are at least for those here there are
still some ways of getting into the
discussion yes so for those who are
staying um we will have some some time
for you to talk to the speakers
afterwards outside a little bit I would
like to thank all of you for joining um
I have negative 20 seconds on the
clock so unfortunately we don't have
much of a time for summary but we hope
that this has been an and insightful
discussion for all of you and we would
encourage you to talk to the panelists
or to reach out to them privately
afterwards and I think the most
important thing to learn is that we all
have something to learn and we all have
something that we can do to help in this
space and so reflection on what we can
do as we move forward is critically
important so thank you to all of our
panelists including our online panelists
and thank you to our audience and our
online audience for your excellent
questions
[Applause]
than